[Aplausos]
[Música]
hay muchas formas de volar
hay quien hace con hadas y nunca sabes
y
quien las tiene y no las tiene
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hay también en este mundo que contempla
el horizonte
[Música]
[Aplausos]
quien sabe volar sin alas
con la imaginación con los sueños por
los caminos andados
[Aplausos]
hay quien está esperando un rayo de luz
para invadir el cielo
apropiarse de él
[Música]
e infectar al mundo de libertad
hay también quien construye sus alas
[Música]
quien no cesa de intentar
[Aplausos]
que no tiene miedo a los abismos porque
confía en su sangre aunque tengo peso
gastado
[Música]
[Aplausos]
también quien tiene sus alas en lugares
inimaginables
[Música]
las salas no sólo son de las aves y de
los que vuelan
las salas están
[Música]
[Aplausos]
esperando despertar para hacerlos libres
cielos lejos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
de nosotros con sables
los grit nos piden vivir estas voces
nunca se callan porque nuestros sueños
están hechos de nuestros anhelos de
nuestros deseos o necesidades de
nuestros recuerdos primigenios en algún
momento de nuestra historia de vida
se incendiaron y piden vivir
pero para hablar en el mundo real en el
lenguaje cotidiano toda idea que nos da
para vivir está condenada a morir
porque la realidad es que tenemos que
enfrentar situaciones prioritarias como
la supervivencia está en la llave para
que nuestros sueños sean nuestra vida
construir un puente entre el mundo de
nuestros sueños y la supervivencia
si es posible aunque parezca
descabellado
yo un día soñé que era posible
transformar el mundo que era posible
crear seres humanos mejores
entrar en el interior de las personas y
poderles ofrecer de sensibilidad
imaginación y cualquier otro centímetro
que ayudará a mejorar esta sociedad y
para aterrizar mi sueño en acciones
reales lo primero que tuve que hacer es
decir bueno desde dónde puedo trabajar
desde dónde puedo yo aportar con todo lo
que soy
mark twain dijo hay dos días importantes
en tu vida el día que naces y el día que
descubres para quién
en esta búsqueda interna yo encontré el
mundo de los títeres que le dieron carne
a mi sueño
los líderes me enseñaron que era posible
entrar en el interior de las personas
transformarlas tocarlas mostrarles un
mundo diferente lleno de imaginación eso
dio resultado al mayor discurso de mi
profesión
yo no puedo cambiar lo que te sucede
lo que sí puedo hacer es mostrarte que
hay otros mundos que hay otros lugares
donde es posible la imaginación la
fantasía es posible convertir la ira la
violencia la desesperanza
en colores en movimientos en diálogos
el mundo de los títeres para mí se
convirtió en todas las artes juntas y
creo de verdad con todo mi corazón que
es posible transformar el mundo
si nos transformamos nosotros desde
adentro el arte entra con fuerza a las
personas y se queda ahí nos hace sentir
vivos nos hace sentir más humanos nos
conecta con nuestro ayer nuestra hora y
nos construye para el mañana
y bueno teniendo este discurso en la
piel me puse a trabajar me puse
abofetear mis alas
y si encontré yo mi proyecto que es casa
de los títeres monitos casa de los
títeres money ni es un foro creado
únicamente para funciones de títeres así
de lo quisimos está mi sueño y bueno lo
primero que te di fue que la seriedad
con lo que yo trataba mis sueños era la
seriedad con que la iba a percibir el
mundo
en mi entorno las personas que estaban
cerca de mí
me puse a trabajar me puse doctora lo
primero que hice fue responderme una
pregunta muy importante para qué quiero
hacer esto
y christian anderson nos dice algo muy
importante en una de sus conferencias
nuestras ideas nos forman una visión
personal del mundo
qué quiere decir esto que cuando
nosotros tenemos conciencia de lo que
somos de nuestros anhelos y de nuestros
deseos
todo se vuelve real todo se vuelve
tangible y realizable nosotros decimos
coloquialmente estamos conectados con el
universo
y de pronto cuando empezamos a realizar
nuestros sueños todos se nos dan
fácilmente se nos acercan personas y
empieza a suceder toda la magia lo que
sucede en realidad es que nuestro
cerebro empieza a detectar cualquier
idea que implemente y que nos haga ver
que es posible lo que estamos haciendo
nuestra idea es posible por ejemplo
cuando tenemos la idea de un embarazo
anoticiado y andamos por la calle se nos
cruce por enfrente señoras con bebés
cargando carritos de bebés
vemos espectaculares con carritos nuevos
pruebas de embarazo vemos escaparates
llenos de productos para bebés todo eso
siempre ha estado ahí nada más que a
nuestro cerebro no le ocupaba esa idea
cuando nosotros nos conectamos y ese
proceso pasa dentro de nosotros
y esto
fue lo primero que yo pensé voy a
realizar mi sueño y voy a estructurar
como empecé a estructural lo que hice
fue investigar absolutamente todo sobre
el tema documentarme entrevistarme con
personas que habían hecho proyectos
similares al mío y descubrí una verdad
maravillosa hay un montón de gente
alrededor del mundo viviendo sus sueños
y realizando proyectos muy similares a
los míos y que esas personas estaban
ansiosas de compartir su idea de ayudar
empujarme para que yo pudiera realizar
mis sueños
una vez que me documente me preparé
investigue todo lo referente al tema
lo que hice fue planificar planear el
tiempo y que tenía y que no tenía dónde
iba a realizarlo como lo iba a realizar
cuantas personas necesitaba cada sueño
tiene su tiempo su latir y su tiempo de
gestación
tenemos que ser muy pacientes y muy
congruentes poner muchas fechas para
nosotros irnos empujando a llegar a esta
meta
una vez que planifique una vez que
investigue me documenté lo siguiente fue
ubicar muy bien mi proyecto es decir
cuál era mi producto porque podría ser
el sueño más absurdo más ambiguo y más
inverosímil que puedan ver las personas
pero lo cierto es que si hubiera una
etiqueta colgando de cada sueño exitoso
realizado diría 99% trabajo 1% idea
original nosotros tenemos que estar muy
conscientes que tenemos que luchar por
lo que somos
me preparé me documenté hice una
contabilidad de mis años de mis dineros
de mi trabajo y abrí casa de los títeres
mami
llegó el día de la inauguración
todo mostró feliz contento al día
siguiente con la sobriedad del día
después me levanté me paré frente al
espejo y dije dios mío qué dices estoy
loca pero respire yo estaba muy
consiente muy consciente de lo que
estaba haciendo y lo hice con todas mis
fuerzas
respire
y regrese a la vida
a los dos días una persona tocó a la
puerta y me dijo oiga usted hace el
interés me puede hacer este títere y me
enseñó una foto lógicamente lo que yo
pensé es que mi madre ya había pagado a
esa persona o mi marido la había mandado
que yo no perdiera la esperanza pero no
esa persona era real y empezó toda una
vida alrededor de mis sueños
todo puede comenzar con un primer
impulso
si tú tienes conciencia de esto nunca
jamás vas a abandonar tu sueño
[Música]
la vida te va a llevar por muchos rumbos
lo importante es saber muy bien a dónde
vas
a
[Música]
porque así nunca vas a olvidar tu camino
ese camino que te lleva a la única meta
de tu vida
que es quienes somos lo que hacemos
y para que los aceros
[Música]
hay muchas formas de volar
[Aplausos]
[Música]